good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Thursday hope
everybody's having an amazing gorgeous
beautiful standing in smart and wickedly
talented day thus far I am are you I am
I don't see any reason why I shouldn't
be I'm a little dare I say jealous
because turdy Lou is in my house and not
my apartment here in New York she's in
my house in Florida in my studio body
Twisted here with me I forgot how much
you know time effort energy we put into
your Florida Studio it's such a a
peaceful place
you can do your best work in here it's
great lighting it's good temperature I
really I'm loving it here I'm happy to
be at your house of course I wish you
were here but you know yesterday
afternoon me and Ben just got the itch
we were like we gotta get down to
Florida we haven't seen them kids in an
eternity and you know what it was a
treacherous Journey but we got here
I'm really excited for you that you're
there I really am jealous like it sounds
really nice to be in Florida right now
in the houses in my area but it's so hot
it's so hot are you gonna swim and stuff
what are you gonna do yeah of course I
gotta get this episode over with and
then my suit is on for the rest of the
day
suit equals on I'm taking Caleb to the
pool we're throwing down we're playing
games we're splashing around are you
gonna go in my pool
no I guess not
I feel like your pool probably hasn't
been like cleaned in a few months no no
they I actually they still come
oh okay what's the temperature
I think it's hot because it's so hot
yeah
I think all pools in Florida are really
hot right now yeah okay well I'll figure
it out
the ocean off the coast of Florida
temperature is about I saw that 100
degrees I saw 101 degrees which is so
crazy like that's the temperature of a
Jacuzzi of a hot tub yeah
no that sounds literally miserable yeah
um so maybe I'll just stay inside today
we'll see we'll see what the Day brings
you know I do want to play Pickleball I
brought my pickleball outfit Coolio I
have some incredible here in my garage
if you need to borrow oh I'm gonna need
to borrow like your rackets and stuff
but I got a really cute like tennis
dress and set with like a skort from
Spanx that I'm really looking forward to
trying on and you need to make sure
Olivia takes out the gift that I gave
her for her birthday because it was like
a pickleball themed gift and you need to
make sure that wench is using it
properly yes ma'am will do
aye aye Captain thank you
so we've got a great show today it's
Thursday we've got stories we've got you
know transatlantic podcasting which we
haven't done in so long I can't believe
we used to do like the podcast like this
so far away so far removed from one
another every single day I know and now
I'm missing it
it's nice I mean I definitely like enjoy
your setup over here it's really
peaceful it's so quiet I mean nobody's
in your house so it's like ideal
podcasting opportunity I don't know if
it's always like this but it's so far
I'm enjoying myself Theo's outside in
your backyard running around living life
I got the motion sensor alert that there
was nothing did you see me in one of
your cameras I gave you a a Chuck to
deuce and gave a kissy face not yet but
I'll go back and watch yeah I wanted you
know I wanted to leave a moment for you
on your phone are you gonna take my car
oh me and Ben were talking about that
yesterday because you know the Shapiro's
have one car and I figure for however
long we're here we probably will need a
second car at some point and you have
you know your mom car and then you have
your Tesla and when the Shapiro's ever
need to borrow a car from you they
always take the Tesla but me and Ben
were saying how much we love your mom
car it's like the easiest car to drive
it's smooth and a Tesla is
um like a
different mode of driving it's not like
how we all learn to drive where like the
car will move if your foot is not on the
brake it's kind of like a go-kart it's
just go and stop going yeah you would
need Shapiro knows how to drive the
Tesla so he would just have to brief you
it's not very difficult you would figure
it out quickly but you just need like a
quick tutorial
no I like the mom car take it it's a
nice vehicle enjoy it that's Zack's car
oh Zach is the mom car yeah I'm glad
someone likes it I like Zack's car it's
so
um spacious the inside is very luxurious
it is and I feel like people respect me
on the road because they're like oh
she's a mom she means business little do
they know she's not a mom she's just the
number one Auntie she's common
misconception but she's Theo's mom
she's also not just an Andy you know
she's more than that what is she
she's a lover a fighter a caregiver you
need a bumper sticker that says that
author New York Times
um yeah I'll have that I'll get to work
yeah so everyone can know everyone know
what's good who they're on the road with
right that she means business
um so what's up with you like I really
didn't talk to you yesterday because I
was just so busy like you know flying
transatlantically what is new with me oh
I had a really busy day yesterday
excited doctor's appointment and then we
recorded the redheads so it was just
busy busy busy and then I was so tired
and exhausted and broken you know you
know how that goes when you're So
Pregnant and your back is gonna break in
half no I see I don't know how that goes
but I have so much respect and sympathy
because like I know what I feel like
after a long day and I'm just like an
out of shape you know regular girl I'm
not creating life I'm not you know
is on a basketball under my stomach you
know so I don't know what it's like and
I I really I'm in awe of you every day
and I'm constantly thinking of you thank
you and our couch here is so
uncomfortable like it's the worst couch
so then in the evenings like Harry's
like sleeping in our room so I only go
into the bed like when I'm gonna read
and go to sleep so I have to spend you
know an hour or two on the couch and
it's just back breaking
no I don't know so Jackie's obviously
not in her house she's in a furnished
rental whoever picked out that couch we
need to talk it first of all no I'm
sorry let's start at the beginning
whoever manufactured that couch like
jail
jail it's like a couch that they would
put in Guantanamo to get people to talk
because like you lay on it for long
enough you're like oh my God I'll say
anything yeah anything to get off this
couch anything to get off this couch
it's so uncomfortable yeah I don't know
what it is about the couch and there's a
few ways of configuring it and people
will be like oh uh my friend has that
couch like we always put the headrest up
I'm like what's the point no your friend
has that couch she wouldn't be my friend
yeah I wouldn't be visiting with her no
I don't know her any longer I miss my
couch
yeah well you could always come over to
my apartment which has the same couch as
your house maybe I should go stay at
your apartment while I'm gone while
you're gone and by the way I just had
the housekeeper come it's [__] and span
I know I just have too much stuff to
like you know obviously I'm not failing
to do that but that's a nice idea unless
you just wanted to take like a mommy
Retreat like Harry and Zach can stay at
the Guantanamo house and you can that
doesn't sound like any time I would just
be sitting there like what am I doing
where's my angel
but you would just be laying like on my
heated mattress and you could watch TV I
would feel weird laying in your bed why
I just changed the sheets not weird like
that just say this is turdy's Lair oh
because that's where me and Ben have sex
no I said not weird like that that is
that way
[Laughter]
Jackie it's a natural part of matrimony
you're just gonna have to get on it said
not like that it's just like what am I
doing in turkey's there without turdy
enjoying relaxing creating life
I'm fine here and I like my bed here I
finally got my bed here to a really good
place
okay my God no need to attack
you're attacking me putting words in my
mouth Jackie you know what it's time you
heard it I have sex
I am a married woman it's okay
I don't know what to say to you I didn't
say anything of the sort I know what
you're thinking you're like turdy has
sex not my turdy my turkey would never
that's what you're thinking no that's
not what I'm thinking
it's what you think of you guys
it's not what I'm thinking
so
moving on
sure you want to stop thinking about it
I I'm done I'm done I'm trying to
navigate this conversation and I can't
because you're just so overwhelmed with
images of me having sex in your brain
I'm on strike oh you're joining I'm
joining well guess what I'm crossing the
picket line to get your ass back here
because we've got work to do we've got
stories Galore I don't know if I would
say Galore you wouldn't know no I
wouldn't know but like I
was like on my phone all day yesterday
and like I didn't get any Crazy People
magazine notifications except Sinead
O'Connor passed away there's no crazy
stories but they're good stories I feel
good about them I feel good I don't feel
I'm not dreading them love that I'm not
pulling teeth I think they're five solid
citizens
but I'm ready to dive in if you are
surely Durley without further Ado here
are the fastest without further without
further early here are the fast five
stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by State Farm
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and when
it comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you at an
affordable price that's created just for
you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences I mean how often are we
staying here on the toast you know
what's more personal than comedy food
poetry life is so personal and insurance
should be too because you're unique
girly you're different you're not like
other insurance holders you require your
own special plan so think about it like
this what are your music playlists
podcast feeds and social media Scrolls
have in common they're all a reflection
of you so we all know my social media is
full of ASMR Taylor Swift theories
celebrity news and that's me because I'm
so different and not like other girls
and that's what the State Farm personal
price plan has in common too it gives
you options to help you personalize your
coverage so you can protect what you
care about at an affordable price just
for you so you can see more of yourself
and everything you love I don't think
today's sponsor could be more
appropriate I'm literally sitting in
Jackie's in short house because she's a
homeowner and I'm not not to rub it in
but she you know
has different needs than me because
we're all so different that's like the
point I'm trying to make here like a
good neighbor State Farm is there call
or go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary like a good name
today's episode is brought to you by
earning life doesn't happen bi-weekly so
why should Payday the money you earn can
be in your hands today with earning
earning is an app that gives you access
to your pay as you work up to a hundred
dollars per day or up to 750 per pay
period just download the earn an app and
verify your paycheck then you can access
up to a hundred dollars a day as you
work and leave an optional tip as any
money you access plus tips are
automatically repaid from your next
paycheck so if I needed something like
earning this is exactly what I would use
because money sometimes isn't moving as
fast as your dreams are and erden
provides the financial momentum that you
need to keep moving forward so you can
download Earn in today it's spelled
e-a-r-n-i-n in the Google Play or Apple
App Store when you download the earn an
app type in toast under podcast when you
sign up it'll help the toast again you
just sign in under podcast select toast
it's subject to your available earnings
daily Max and pay period Max see
earning.com TOS for details earning is a
financially trusted company not a a bank
bank products are issued by evolve Bank
and Trust member FDIC make earning a
part of your financial routine and join
earnings over three and a half million
customers who say things like when I
think about earning I think about
financial stability and security it
gives me a lot of peace of mind so again
download the earning app e-a-r-n-i-n in
the Google Play or Apple App Store and
when you download the earn an app type
in toast under podcast when you sign up
that's toast under podcast subject
available to your earnings daily Max and
pay period Max see earning.com TOS for
details thanks turdy you're welcome and
thanks Armin you're welcome
our first story Travis Kelsey says he
tried to give Taylor Swift his number at
the arrows tour but ended up
disappointment disappointed
so Travis took to his podcast New
Heights with his Brethren Jason and
shared that he went to the Taylor Swift
concert this week and he tried and
failed to meet tailored at one of her
stops on the Eris tour he said
apparently the pop star keeps a tight
lock on the tour's backstage area and
made no exception for him he said quote
I was disappointed that she doesn't talk
before or after her shows because she
has to save her voice for the 44 songs
that she sings she admitted to being a
little he admitted to being a little
butt hurt that he wasn't able to execute
his plan to deliver a personalized
bracelet to Swift he said I didn't get
to hand her one of the bracelets I made
for her the bracelet that he made for
her apparently had his number on it his
phone number and Jason Kelsey being the
pjam that he is thought that Travis made
him made her like a friendship bracelet
with his football jersey number on it
yeah and he was like no my cell phone
number yeah so he's trying to woo our
girl and I don't know if she knew I
think she has probably has like a
totally closed door policy period like
makes no exceptions I've seen pictures
like the law they saw her like very few
but they were Kelly and Miles Teller
Kelly and Miles Teller yeah you're right
actually she's very selective like of
course she can't be hobnobbing and like
drinking and you know
socializing she has only so much energy
now I have a few things to say
would I ship these two in a heartbeat
absolutely am I ready for Taylor to date
like this All-American big old football
yes I'm so here for it
having said all of that
ever since the Super Bowl I feel like I
said this in the weeks after the Super
Bowl and it's still kind of raining true
Travis Kelsey is a little thirsty just a
little yeah he is as much as if Taylor
came out you know tomorrow and said I'm
with Travis Kelsey I would be obsessed
but if you're asking me like if I would
put the two of them together I actually
would not I do not think that they're a
match I think that they're so different
I can't um see her with him or him with
her again if they could overcome their
differences and be together I would
support it wholeheartedly but if I'm
playing Raven Simone I just don't see a
future for these two no and you are
playing Raven Symone so I'm so glad you
brought that up however I do think that
these two should definitely explore each
other's bodies like I think that would
be an exciting afternoon for them but on
a relationship level I agree I don't
think they're compatible I think they'd
both be disappointed in the other
yeah and I don't think it's actually a
good match having said that if they fell
in love I'd be so here for it but mostly
because like Travis's image and like
what we know about him like I'm I'm
really I feel like she's always dating
like British like skinny boys no it's
not even about looks like she likes a
serious guy she's a serious girl she's
an artist she likes a fellow artist she
likes someone with depth and Travis is
is silly yeah yeah yeah well I didn't
want to say that but yeah why I think
that's a good thing like I don't know
I'm not saying one's better than the
other Travis is like a jokester I just
don't see them like intellectually
vibing I think that's really important
to Taylor but maybe I mean it hasn't
worked out thus far with her you know
deep artists boyfriends maybe somebody
like light and
silly is exactly what she needs like she
kind of has like such a serious life
everything she does she like puts all of
her effort into and she takes everything
in her career really seriously so it'd
be nice to come home it's like a little
bit of a clown yeah do you she's never
dated an athlete has she no she's never
had an athlete era and she's like
playing all these stadiums like it's
bound to happen
okay well maybe she'll see this story
she'll probably write him off
just because it's thirsty to then like
go on his podcast and talk about it you
know but he didn't say anything I don't
think so I actually didn't say anything
bad he didn't say anything bad I don't
think it's thirsty that he went on his
his podcast to talk about it
with his brother I think it's cute
I think it's a little thirsty
but you go on your podcast to talk about
stuff with your sister all the time no
and I'm admittedly an extremely thirsty
person but I still think Taylor should
give you the time of day
honestly
as much as I want her to like would it
be in her best interest I don't know
Trudy don't don't negative self-talk
you'd be a great friend Taylor also I
watched like a bunch of that episode
because they were talking about Taylor
and they also did like a whole
conversation on Madden rankings do you
know what that is no
it took me like a really long time to
figure it out but Ben helped me so
Madden is like the the game it's like a
video game and it comes out every year
for the NFL and a bunch of different
sports and every year they the players
get ranked out of a hundred they get a
score and so they were going over their
individual scores out of 100 on the
podcast Jason I Know Travis Kelsey got
out of 199. wow Jason got a 92. okay and
then I was just like looking up
everybody else's numbers like I thought
it was so interesting you know yeah that
is interesting and it's funny that
they're talking about it
publicly like I'm sure all the players
look at their scores
yeah Kyle youth check posted he was like
mine should have been higher that's
really funny
yeah I think it's like a cute little
thing that like little football girlies
do
well hopefully that will impress Taylor
maybe she plays Madden in her Spare Time
backstage after a show yeah
that's a good call well she knows where
to find him if this story reaches her
and she looks at his face and wants to
see it
yeah I mean what it couldn't hurt you
know to have one date maybe one you know
romp in the sack
yeah I just don't see it
no I don't see it on a capacity if they
like sat down for drinks what on God
screen diddly dally Earth would they
talk about they've both hosted SNL so
they could start there
where are the Kelsey's from
oh Taylor is an Eagles fan with my
Eagles team by the door why his brother
plays for the eagles they could talk
about like beat the Eagles
but Taylor has like a knowledge of
football they could talk a little bit
about that they have both of a deep
knowledge of stadiums they can talk
about their favorite stadiums in the
country this sounds like a horrible date
it sounds like a horrible date it's thin
we talked about our favorite stadiums do
you see her writing a lyric about that I
don't
see that [__] could write a lyric about
anything like
and she'd found a way to make it
stunning and poetic yeah
so good luck Travis keep up the good
keep up your efforts but don't get your
hopes up don't get your hopes up
our next story Ariana Grande's boyfriend
Ethan Slater files for divorce from his
wife Lily J
Ikes the SpongeBob musical live on stage
star filed for divorce from his wife in
New York Wednesday according to legal
documents obtained by Page Six
the official reason for the split was
unclear though in the documents this
most recent development comes nearly a
week after his relationship with Ari
became public
wow this is really adding insult to
injury like that he was the one to file
yeah and this makes it much more real I
feel like you could always say we don't
have proof there's that one picture of
them at a cast dinner right it doesn't
really mean that much it could be
speculative Like You could argue but
Ethan it's not too late to stop the
papers like what are you doing I mean I
think it's too late to stop the papers
on her behalf she's like [__] this
I don't know if Ethan came home this
like now it's just like a week or two of
pain like I think they could get through
it no I would never want to be with
someone like that like who you know he's
not going to give up his career if this
is what he does to make a living so he's
so easily swept up in like the Hollywood
you're on your first movie dude like be
in like your one-year-old is not even
enough to keep you on the straight
narrow I would never like to me it's
such a yeah people make mistakes but
it's so indicative of a lack of
integrity and like a character flaw I
would never I agree and if I ever could
it would be incredibly hard but like for
the sake of a one-year-old they're also
High School sweethearts like The Roots
Run Deep here
it's so terrible and I'm really curious
I don't know if it means anything I've
been told that it doesn't like for who
who files but
why him
I know he's running away with R.A
maybe Ari was like get divorced
no and Ari literally in a week is gonna
be like I never said that go home
literally Ethan stop no I'm hating this
whole story it's making me hate everyone
involved like I'm really not genuinely I
really try not to be a judgmental person
I you know people make mistakes I'm like
very understanding of that and I just
try to not to judge other people's life
choices but it's literally impossible
for me not to judge honestly both of
them his poor judgment in in sacrificing
his family his Shalom bite and her for
choosing him like what no also sometimes
when people
act wrong in relationships like we
always say you know if if they stay
together forever like it would be okay
you know it would make it worth it like
it's true love even if these two were to
grow old together
never look at another person in their
entire lives I would still think it's
wrong no and of course Nothing in life
is certain nothing is guaranteed but we
know for certain that these two will not
be together forever they won't even be
together for another month no I know
that but I'm saying even if they were to
be even if she marries him they go to
the London Courthouse and they get
married next week like it doesn't change
anything
agreed
it's really
you know this is a strong word but it's
despicable mm-hmm
and I'm judging hard yeah yeah
and if any you know divorce attorneys
want to sound off in the comments like
what does him filing mean does that give
him an advantage does it give her an
advantage like let me know yeah
maybe he wants out like maybe he doesn't
want to be an adulterer right or is he
just like running away from his family
yeah like he fell in love with another
woman and he wants his freedom
this is humiliating for this man like I
hate this man yeah
I don't know if I can see the movie
it's giving tainted energy I don't know
if I can support the project
I know we have to you know
as consumers consciously power yeah
that's our power
yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
some surprising news as Selena Gomez is
celebrating her kidney donor's birthday
Francia rasa amid the rumored Feud so so
Selena posted on Instagram for Francia
races 35th birthday she said happiest of
birthdays to this special human being no
matter where life takes us I love you
uh as we all know Francia donated a
kidney to Selena and then the terms of
their friendship
seemed to wane ebb and flow and up until
this morning Francia was not even
following Selena on Instagram but Selena
was following Francia yeah the the the
said I have read and heard is that
and also did you watch the documentary
when Francia was talking about donating
the kidney
in Salinas documentary
yeah she was an insulinous documentary
I'm sorry it wasn't that documentary it
was something
she talked about the experience
and she basically said like
Selena found out that Francia was a
match before Francia found out so Selena
brought the news turns friends he was
like I felt like I had no choice like it
wasn't this like you know Kumbaya
gorgeous moment Hallelujah it was like
fraught with Peril and then the two
slowly like distance themselves from one
another and stopped following liking
each other's photos whatever and people
started to notice and the Rumor was that
like Francia was mad that like
Selena hadn't changed you know her
lifestyle choices
with this new kidney and like wasn't
properly taking care of it and then like
Francia was like done with her I now I
think this post disproved that for a lot
of people even though it's weird that
she made that post when Francia wasn't
following her on Instagram Francia
followed her like this morning and she
posted this yesterday yeah the whole
thing is weird from top to bottom it was
it's been weird since she gave her the
kidney and then you stopped talking to
your Kidney donor who was once your
friend like that's weird if I I've heard
the rumors that you've heard about why
they stopped talking because Selena
didn't change her behavior I would if I
were her kidney don't I'd be [__]
pissed too you take care of my kidney
wench yeah
um hair break a new one so like but I
feel like Selena has never acknowledged
that there that there was beef between
them and like her kind of like
delusionally posting for her birthday
like as if everything's hunky-dory isn't
like it it kind of jives with everything
else that she does
yeah but so why would Francia re-follow
her this morning
I don't know I think that that that
signals that maybe they are on the mend
I feel like this was Selena's way of
kind of shutting everyone up because
people are always talking about this
asking questions and
Francia has like liked stuff on social
media that would point to like her being
resentful like there's a lot there
people aren't making this up so it felt
like this was Selena's way of like
appeasing everyone and being like shut
up but I think it made people ask more
questions especially in the caption you
know no matter where life takes us
really sounds like something like you
say to someone who you're not close with
yeah and that like life has taken us to
other places other places right
but regardless of those places I love
you
which is a beautiful sentiment and she
should you know the girl gave her her
kidney right
this is a crazy this is one of those
things in pop culture that's like such a
mystery and I would really truly
genuinely love to know what the truth is
like you know like when you die they're
like you can know anything I'd be like
what the hell happened between these two
I'm so curious It's the weirdest Saga
and at first I would like had a feeling
I'm like I feel like they're not friends
anymore and then everyone else started
to think that and then point out like
Francia liking stuff and commenting
stuff on social media and like more
proof and I was like oh
yeah it's real you know it's so odd also
the photos from the carousel that she
posted like do seem kind of dated so
it's not like they're like hanging out
yesterday actively yeah
no it's
it's definitely something that uh you
know we should think about you know keep
an eye out for Selena and Francia yeah
and also the quote from her documentary
where Selena said that Taylor was her
only friend in the industry that yes
thank you that is what um I saw Francia
comment on like somebody had made a
graphic a Selena fan account of the
moment in her documentary where Selena
said the Taylor is her only friend in
the industry and Francia commented being
like wow
I mean wow and then Selena commented on
a post showing francia's comment
and Selena like
replied back like very harshly I didn't
mean that like defending herself very
defensive and that was like a full
confirmation for people that these two
weren't deeply unwell he
I forgot about that yes Taylor always in
the middle of stuff yeah so maybe they
have gotten back together and are
seeing each other as friends once again
because I think it has to be that
otherwise why would Selena give more
light to the situation I feel like it
was finally quieting down like we all
just moved on and we're like they're not
friends anymore that's weird but that
happens I guess
you know I have a question that I'd like
to ask our you know our audience is
anybody here given or received any sort
of organ okay what is your relationship
like with that person do you see and
talk to them every day is it you know
was it someone you knew or was if it's
just a donor from a list like
no that doesn't count I'm talking about
like somebody in your life who gave you
I I can't relate to this relationship in
any way shape or form so if anybody is
given or receiving an organ to someone
in their life who they knew or currently
know what is your relationship like with
that person I imagine it's good I don't
think they talk every day but like you
know birthdays holidays weddings
weddings the big stuff like you're
always included and
you have a special place in my heart you
have a special place in my heart maybe
that's what Selena was just trying to
say yeah
let me read happy birthdays to this
special human being no matter where life
takes us I love you that could mean like
we're not friends whatsoever but happy
birthday and I love you for the kidney
for the kidney
it's definitely a unique situation I'll
say that it is it is a unique situation
it's unlike any other story we've ever
talked about on the toast it's it's
honestly one of the most mind-boggling
stories like
like this girl literally gave you her
kidney and you're gonna be mad at her
like somebody gives you their kidney
like they could literally run you over
with a car like they're like you can't
be mad at them well no I think like
Francia was mad at Selena yeah yeah yeah
that's only I think Selena got mad at
Francia for being mad at her yeah and
then they stopped being friends and so
Selena said that thing like I only have
one friend in the industry and then
Francia was like
even though I hate you like I can still
give you a kidney in defense of Selena
what she was I think saying at that time
in her documentary really had nothing to
do with Francia and I guess francia's
completely in the industry but there are
about 10 people in the world who could
relate to the level of Fame that Selena
Gomez has and Taylor Swift happens to be
her best friend so I really don't think
it was a slight at France yeah Francia
yeah of course is famous but Francia is
not even close
to the level of like the lack of privacy
all of the things that really only
Taylor Selena and a handful other people
of other people on the planet know what
know what that's like yeah but she
definitely should be more you know
conscious of her words when she's
dealing with yeah because then I'm like
okay is Nicola a friend in the industry
yes no but not
she's Nicholas the same as Francia right
right
okay and they're both levels beneath
Taylor
yeah
are you ready for our next story
no you're not
it is our next story that's brought to
you by eBay any chance the one you're
talking about perchance it is
for Chad's today's episode of the toast
is brought to you by eBay authenticity
guarantee Jackie and I love to invest
you know Jackie loves to invest in
Jackie also loves to motivate others to
invest so whether it's purses clothing
shoes we are always making sure to shop
smart with eBay authenticity guarantee
eBay authenticators are there verifying
every detail of your purchase so eBay
authenticity guarantee protects buyers
from fakes and gives them the assurance
that they're getting the real deal what
is worse than spending time money energy
scouring the internet finding your next
investment only to later find out that
you have been scammed you know it's a
wild west out here on the internet and
we got to be smart we got to be you know
conscious consumers as we were saying
earlier and eBay's out here trying to
help the conscious consumer with eBay
authenticity guarantee you'll never get
faked over again the service currently
covers eligible items across sneakers
watches handbags jewelry and streetwear
we feel more confident in ordering
online knowing that an expert at eBay is
authenticating our items any purchase
backed by authenticity guarantee is sent
to the authentication team who
personally inspect the item check it
against the listing and authenticate it
in a world full of fakes it's time to
get real with eBay authenticity
guarantee ensure your next purchase is
the real deal with eBay authenticity
guarantee everyone deserves real visit
ebay.com for terms thank you termsia
terms yeah you're welcome okay our next
Story start jaggy termsia Raisa
our next story is a little collab news
collab X not what you would think though
Drake is bringing Snapchat on tour using
AR filter on the crowds so just listen
Drake is joining forces with Snapchat to
bring one of the social media platform's
most popular filters with him on tour
and the results are quite the sight to
see so he recently started using a new
feature on crowd shots at his show like
where they show the crowd and it goes up
on the screen but you know that AR
filter from Snapchat where it looks like
the person's crying
yes that's got that's like their most
popular filter so now when he plays his
song laugh now cry later the screen
shows audience members with the Snapchat
lens on their face like crazy very funny
I've you know Drake is kind of like
making waves with this tour maybe it's
only because it was just in New York and
everyone I knew went
um okay because he has this thing where
he like throws he asks people to like
throw their bras on stage oh I didn't
see that and I actually we we were
talking on the redheads yesterday
because Dana went to the Drake show in
New York two nights ago with Zach and we
were talking about how like this tour is
actually making no waves
well okay and also why is he doing two
nights at Barclays and two nights at MSG
like what about what could he do one
night at MetLife it's also kind of weird
that like he isn't doing the stadium
tour when like he's Drake
yeah I wonder why that's actually and
he's on tour with 21 Savage
yeah I think they could sell out MetLife
so why don't they
I wonder if you make more money touring
is so interesting like when you
to do like one Stadium show like the way
I know that it works okay for like my
level of touring is like you can play
The Beacon Theater like four times and
sell as many tickets as one time at
Radio City so you would think oh why
don't I just do one time at Radio City
you do four shows at Beacon Theater
you'll make like triple maybe more the
money so sometimes like for a lot of
comedians who can do like one night at
Radio City or one night and then at MSG
one night at MSG it's an expensive you
know you hope you pay a lot of fees so
you could do one item MSG or six nights
at Radio City like you make way more
money at the smaller venue doing it
multiple times so it could be a money
thing I don't know how it works for
stadiums though that's what that was my
guess because if he's doing four
the uh Arenas right that's what they are
then he could probably sell out in that
life and he's also like one of the
biggest artists in the world like I
think he definitely could but
um it must be just about profits or it
was about scheduling because like right
now Post cover this is like the first
summer of Arena tours where like Beyonce
Taylor Ed Sheeran Luke Combs and Morgan
Wallen are all playing Arenas so it's
hard to get dates
um
like everyone's competing I mean Taylor
must have done it first because she
booked every [__]
American
Stadium weekend for the summer like
literally she's been on tour since it's
been nice out like what did the tour
start may she may to August what are
there 40 stadiums in the country let's
just say yeah and there's four touring
artists going to State five fat
yeah I guess no one was at MetLife this
weekend
you're definitely competing like for
because then you also have to think
about yeah okay so Taylor Swift played
MetLife this weekend why can't Ed
Sheeran play the next one then you're
also just competing for people's money
like disposable income is only so you
know it's not unlimited so people are
going to decide oh in this month Beyonce
and Taylor are coming to my town most
people are gonna be like well I'm gonna
go to one
okay it's also expensive I'm just
guessing here just guessing but anyways
uh yeah Drake did come to New York this
week signaling to us that he's on tour
yeah and now I'm like hearing so much
about it what'd you hear
sounds like a great time everyone's
throwing stuff on stage but he asks
people to do that not like in the way
you know Kelsea ballerini or pink or uh
Bebe rexa was right right
um and I like this SnapChat partnership
I think that's so funny me too really
cute but I also think that that
the the filter that I'm thinking of is
on Tick Tock I'm sure it's really
similar yeah
I it looks like to be the same where
it's like that crying face wow yeah it's
cute it's honey yeah I think it's a
funny guy yeah he is and this is
um ingenuity
and Drake's on a podcast did you see I
did see who did we talk about this on
the toast no but what what is that
podcast it's like parody
yeah okay so she is a tick tocker I've
seen her on Tick Tock a bunch
um and she does like a lot of mom
content which I was so surprised that he
went on
um especially because this is her third
episode ever
what but also the so I saw a clip from
the podcast and it was so awkward and I
was like oh my God yeah that's her
that's her uh my friend I was like is
this girl okay like Drake just burned
like her at the stake and then I went to
the show page I was watching more clips
and they're all kind of like that that's
her thing I think I saw a comment like
it's kind of like Between Two Ferns
where it's like yes unbelievable not to
be believed interview
yes she has like this character that she
plays
it was really funny I fell for it yeah
no it's really it's funny it's just
crazy that she launched a podcast and
her third guest ever was Drake I mean
her third episode ever
was he just like a fan of her Tick Tock
he must be he's like an internet user
you know I feel like he he probably like
found her and just thought she was funny
that's just so crazy yeah
you'd love to see Drake out here
supporting women in podcasting
you do and you know the only other show
I feel like he's went on even somewhat
recently is that um what the [__] is it
called
Caleb Presley what's his show called ice
cream sundae I don't know it that blonde
hair guy with really he has long blonde
hair and he is it's a Barstool show it's
called ice cream sundae yeah
does he have another show
he's like all over Barstool okay
and he was also recently on theobon
who Caleb Caleb I I've heard of Caleb
and like Luke did his show Luke did a
show and so if you watch his show it's
very similar that he's like playing a
character and he asks like weird
questions and he makes it awkward so
that's obviously like Drake's brand of
humor yeah
yeah at least you know he's consistent I
dig it
I dig it are you ready for our fifth and
final story yes
Mattel executives are talking about
their next Hollywood moves and
establishing a Mattel universe
so the new CEO of Mattel who has a
vision for turning the Story Toy Company
into an IP driven machine is essentially
creating a Mattel Cinematic Universe now
with the immense success of Barbie the
path is clear for Mattel to make
whatever they want and they already have
a ton of projects in the works with
A-list Partners attached so they have
dozens of children's toys and on their
film slate and now 14 Mattel Properties
are an active development including
Barney which we did discuss a few weeks
ago Polly Pocket starring Lily Collins
and directed by Lena Dunham directed by
Lena dominum Thomas and Friends American
Girl and many more American Girl
starring Vin Diesel I feel like they're
on their way and probably what they
modeled it after is like Marvel yeah
let's see like they have all these
characters they and the characters
already have stories and they already
have audiences and now then they'll be
like you know crossovers like how
Avengers end game had like four
different franchises and they'll have
like Barbie the Bratz dolls you know
Polly Pocket all go on on one Adventure
yeah
it's very smart I'm surprised that
like up until this point they hadn't
done any films
yeah I think it will get a little
tiresome not well yes but also a little
confusing because I think Barbie was
like the perfect movie to make for
adults about a children's toy but like
are all of these going to be for
Millennials like that's a little weird
if we're all watching Kids characters
all the time yeah because Barbie was not
for kids not that it was inappropriate
in any way it was just kind of mature
yeah and it was for adults like when
it's a kids movie I grew up playing
Barbie yeah when it's a kid's movie it's
like the kids go and you know and the
parents go but not
it was for adults it was for like
Millennials right so like Polly Pocket
starring Lily Collins like who's that
for
and also I don't like Polly Pocket is
obviously iconic we've all heard of it
but I don't know if we all have this
Barbie was really you're right perfect
because Barbie was a when it came out
and ever since a global like it shifted
the culture like it was this insane
franchise and I don't know if Polly
Pocket had that impact yeah I think
American girls are really good even
though they have been making American
Girl movies like don't knock
don't make movies for American Girl
dolls yeah
kit kit kittridge
starring Anna Sophia Rob
oh yes Anna Sophia I love her it was a
great movie and I saw it as a kid
but then it was obviously for kids
yeah that was for kids but I'm just I
feel like the Barbie the Barney one that
we were talking about is like targeted
for Millennials like
once in a while it's it's cute and
nostalgic for Millennials to go back and
watch their favorite characters as kids
but like
14 movies of kids toys no yeah I don't
know that's not that doesn't that's not
good
that's not good well I think they would
consider Barbie a major success so I
don't think they've been deterred from
their plan I know but I'm just saying to
you like if we're playing Raven Simone
this is all sounds well and good I just
could get see it getting sticky when
like I'm going to sit down to watch
Polly Pocket
and you know that really begs the
question what about a Raven Simone film
well a lot of these films have Studios
and producers but they don't have stars
yet so there is opportunity maybe raven
could play an American Girl doll
but I want Raven's mind I want Raven
producing one of these she's she's a
real
um
Talent Hot Wheels is getting a movie
directed by JJ Abrams
oh but he's a good director what did he
do
lost yeah so it's like going to be
psychological Hot Wheels but he he could
do like he could do anything whatever
you know he's also great father I think
a lot of people don't know that Star
Wars and Star Trek but the description
has the adaptation as grounded and
gritty the film will have characters
real characters that you can relate to
that are three-dimensional that have
emotional Journeys look at any JJ Abrams
movie all of his movies have an
incredible story and Incredible
characters that was something that was
important to him
okay I mean it's literally toy cars
everybody needs to calm down Hot Wheels
this is what I'm saying it's Hot Wheels
and It's Hot Wheels
so it's a little serious it's a little
serious and you and you know how they
describe the Barney one which if you
missed that episode they described it as
an a24 type of surrealistic movie right
I remember that what the [__] does that
mean
I don't know but it was gonna I feel
like it was gonna have like a dark
like
psychological Thriller
aspect excellent yeah unique
unique you know much like everything
else we'll just have to wait and say
yeah
but
it is what it is
and those are the best five those are
the Fast Five
certainly needed to know
every single one of them I think that
you did
yeah I think you're better off for it
we've got one more episode tomorrow
that's really all she wrote That's All
She Wrote
yep
shall I lead us out Jacqueline please
please
lead us out
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Millennium Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
available
talented we are because an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow four ah
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday get down on Friday bye
love ya bye